[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo inédite exclusive impressionnante
insérer un adjectif un peu style et qui
la met en valeur maintenant où il ya
quelques temps j'ai fait une vidéo qui
parler d'actualité sur youtube je
m'étais fait kiffer je vous avais dit
que je voulais parler de ce que j'aime
de ce qui me fait de différents sujets
aujourd'hui c'est la production
officielle de ce nouveau format qui va
tt d'actualité de ce qui s'est passé sur
le net c'est un format inédit innovants
je suis un vieux du monde veut entendre
mon avis alors c'est parti pour le
premier ya alors on commence aujourd'hui
aider les jeunes ouvert notre premier
sujet qui est plus tellement d'actu mais
il faut en parler parce qu'il ya deux
trucs très intéressant à propos de ça
dont j'ai envie de parler et ce comme
j'étais énervé en tout - là dessus mais
de quoi pas tu lucas à tout ça il va
sûrement gagner du temps pour avoir les
dix minutes de vidéo
laurent ruquier le 19 janvier dernier il
anime et sa célèbre émission on n'est
pas couché dans laquelle ils tuent sur
place littéralement les invités à faire
des blagues sur youtube arrive pourtant
c est vous êtes même déjà vieilli par
rapport aux plus hauts du bois comme on
l'a vu cette promo pour mettre en avant
notre dernière création et il avait
comme invité d'honneur la nouvelle miss
france en veille manama chaves jab je
sais pas comment disent non je m'excuse
désolé comme à chaque début d'émission
laurent wauquiez a introduit qui sont
les invités mais ce jour-là on sait pas
ce qui lui prend il craque son slip et
il fait une double gaffe
même les gens les plus maladroits de ce
monde n'avait pas atteint un tel niveau
de gars fric taux de natalité c'est
comme les salaires il n'augmente plus il
y a donc de moins en moins de naissances
est de plus en plus de visites sur
youporn sur les réseaux sociaux et on
regarde de plus en plus les séries sur
netflix
voilà on n'a plus le temps de faire
d'enfants en france le rapport le
rapport le rapport quel est le rapport
il a relié le fait qu'ils aient moins de
naissances au fait que les gens vont sur
internet et regarde des séries et films
en streaming
d'ailleurs vous qui nous regardent et en
ce moment dans votre lit pour relancer
la natalité nous avons invité ce soir
notre miss france ça devrait vous donner
des idées voilà je mets des traducteurs
pour relancer la natalité
nous avons invité une femme sur le
plateau que nous réduisons uniquement à
l'état d'objet qui vous donne envie de
baiser
alors il ya plusieurs choses qui me font
très mal dans cet extrait la première
gêne à dire la deuxième c'est la
réaction
cette détresse la plus totale elle
reprend ses dires voulait vraiment
relancer la natalité
ce qui veut dire clairement mais quelle
grosse merde bien tu te dire éric et qui
utilise l'accord de secours il faut une
question totalement hors sujet vous
voulez être maman est ce qu'un jour une
femme arrivera sur un plateau télé et
les gens ne font aucune remarque sur sa
vie perso ou sur son physique
est ce qu'un jour ça arrivera maintenant
deux jours très très mieux une femme que
laurent ruquier
ah bah on s'amuse avec ses petits effet
tout ça laurent wauquiez il a fait ce
qu'on appelle une martin solveig qui
après avoir remis la première récompense
de l'histoire le ballon d'or féminin lui
demandent est ce que tu sais tout
marquée non toutes les réactions sont
parfaites aussi bien de la concernée que
2ème balle piquée dans le public et
qu'ils aient envie de décéder et de joie
forme ait on peut dire est ce que
l'audience a fait une mba t excuse
publique on n'est pas couché à une
réaction m bape est peut-être pour
relancer la natalité nous avons invité
miss france ça devrait vous donner des
idées voilà mais la deuxième chose qui
me gêne c'est ce petit tacle dans son
intro il met sur le dos d'internet et de
netflix le fait que les gens fassent
moins d'enfants en quoi internet et
netflix empêcherait plus que la télé les
gens de faire des enfants a cessé j'aime
c'est win oui car ce qu'est la télé
c'est de la merde on préfère faire
l'amour alors que ce qu'il ya sur
netflix internet c'est un peu plus
palpitant et du coup on est plus plonger
dedans c'est tout pour moi c'est leur
marque objectifs de la vidéo comme s'il
n'était fixe internet étaient les grands
méchants qui empêchait la télé de vivre
aujourd'hui avec la télé citer les
petits gentil les amis vous venez de
signer pour produire la 20e saison de
inspecteur barnaby inspecteurs dans le
nom de la série il ya le mot inspecteurs
déjà ce mot est plus vieux que laurent
ruquier
george est un vieux discours de jeunes
qui est anti vieux et tout mais c'est
pas ça c'est juste
il ya des freins aux progrès je trouve
juste netflix ya rien a accusé c'est
juste des gens qui ont une très bonne
idée
tout le monde adore cette manière de
consommer la on a le choix on regarde ce
qu'on veut il ya plein de trucs
différents et ça fait place à comme des
productions françaises qui songe champ
mais comme par exemple 10% et qui
dispose d'ailleurs sur des trucs
alors oui aussi plein de trucs de merde
mais c'est mon avis et c'est subjectif
au moins y en a pour tous les goûts
contrairement à ce que france
télévisions propose bon après ce moment
clichés où un mec du net bâche la télé
passons à notre deuxième sujet qui se
trouve juste là bas
monde
il fait froid ici je suis très fier de
cet effet ah ça pour ckoi laurent
ruquier il adore deuxième sus de suse et
suzette un peu plus chaleureux
ok on sort un peu de la télé et des
propos déplacés là c'est un truc assez
cool c'est un mystère on va enquêter
tous ensemble pour tenter de résoudre
l'énigme qui a bouleversé le monde
mercredi dernier à montréal des gens se
baladent et tombe sur un dessin d'un
ours de neige
pourquoi tout le monde en a parlé
derrière parce qu'il ya un détail
frappant le nombril de cette source
il n'y a pas de traces autour du nombril
comment ont-ils pu accéder à ça ils ont
forcément utiliser un objet long pour
appuyer au centre de la neige d'autres
ont dit qu'ils y sont allés au trône il
ya même quelqu'un qui est allé jusqu'à
dire qu'ils ont lancé un nom c'est quoi
est-ce qu'on va être obligé de dire que
c'est des extraterrestres qui ont fait
ça parce qu'on n'a pas encore compris
comment ils ont fait vous avez la
réponse moi je l' ai beaucoup trop
heureusement aujourd'hui vous êtes bien
tomber les loustics carmouze et drake
inspecteurs squeeze rendons-nous tout
d'abord sur cette fameuse photo
je propose de faire un zoom c'est le
nombril encore encore voilà stop plus
aux zooms plus la qualité se détériore
mais si on pratique un désordre voilà je
le savais le nombril est en fait une
photo de l'ours de noix une autre
enquête m'appelle l'histoire elle avait
super lent les mecs ont carrément donné
une interview à un média l'interview
qu'est ce qu'elle dit eh ben ils ont
juste lancer des boules de neige au
milieu du truc pour que ça fasse à un
nombril décevant il est maintenant temps
nous diriger vers le troisième sujet de
cette vidéo et du premier ya quoi
d'ailleurs et permettant même si le
programme bouclé et par et la vidéo sur
les réseaux
venez vous aussi à ma chaîne secondaire
pendant le trajet schéma petit pull quoi
[Musique]
au nom que se passe-t-il quoi ou devrais
je dire y'a quoi c'est la prison y a
plein d'actus autour de la prison en ce
moment est-ce que c'est triste bien
évidemment aux états unis dans une
prison je crois vers new york
il ya eu une panne de chauffage savez il
ya une énorme vague de froid qui a
frappé les états unis il ya donc une
prison le chauffage était en panne et
les détenus ont eu très très froid et
pour montrer leur mécontentement ils ont
tapé sur leurs barreaux tout est triste
dans cette news mais de l'extérieur
le son de ces prisonniers qui tapait sur
les barreaux ça faisait une petite
musique je vous propose de l'écouter
ensemble je n'ai même pas écouté
d'accord donc ça c'est ma news ça c'est
un contenu que je peux en avant dans ma
vidéo un vrai de l'extérieur ça paraît
mignon mais c'est hyper bas dans ce qui
se passe de nom pourquoi j'ai parlé de
ce nom mais vous comprenez pas quoi mais
je veux dire le contraste entre la
musique douce qu'on peut entendre de
l'extérieur parfaitement en contraste
avec la situation terrible qui lit à
l'intérieur du batik sujets suivants il
y en a pas ok je viens on va finir que
la prison alors vous dites mais il est
sacrément con pourquoi il a joué parler
de ça alors que ces deux sujets ils les
trouvent nulle nom et un troisième point
où je veux arriver
voilà c'est celui-là est ce que c'est en
train d'abuser de cet effet bah oui oui
ça oui je fais un rêve régulièrement où
je me retrouve à aller en prison pour un
acte que je n'ai pas commis
alors ça reste un cauchemar mais quand
je me réveille je suis méga en bad
à tel point que j'y pense dans la
journée je me dis mais pourquoi je fais
ce que ça veut dire quoi est-ce que
c'est lié au fait que j'ai pas tenu la
porte aux clients à la fnac ou au fait
que j'aie décapiter un pote la semaine
dernière et que j'ai peur de faire
griller je comprends pas qu'esquisser
écologie - comme hélas pour moi
messieurs dames et va répondre à mes
questions les plus folles devant vous
pourquoi je fais ça en vidéo je sais pas
j'ai en tout très perso j'aurais dû
faire seul ensuite chez moi mais je
préfère le faire avec vous alors
interprétation de prison solitude
enfermement mentale activités
contraignante quotidien aliénant bombe à
l école la signification de ce cauchemar
elle et elle est géniale
et on va donc passer à la fin de cette
vidéo merci d'avoir j'abuse mais effet
je sais mais là j'aimerais avoir être
entouré de choses qui met bien
mentalement donc si on peut mettre juste
là un petit décor du psy voilà ok c'est
bon je me sens mieux une petite musique
des temps de type ascenseur cabinet
thérapeute voilà je suis prêt à lire
mais ça veut dire on y vante les rêves
de prison sont liées à un enfermement
mental un sentiment de liberté restreint
dans la réalité
une vie qui échappent à notre contrôle
dimon tuer ça fait mal mais au plus fort
la musique c'est cet enfermement et
parfois générés par un sentiment de
culpabilité
une faute auraient été commises dont la
raison échappe mais dans la prison
serait la sanction
pourquoi une flèche va bien pourquoi le
rêveur ou la rêveuse se sont obligés
d'exercer la journée une profession très
astreignante pour gagner sa vie
or c'est un point ne laisse aucune
possibilité d'expression de la
personnalité booba où on en est là une
bombe à eau
ok psychologies.com ok mais moi c'est
quoi le rapport
je suis épanoui dans mon métier mais
surtout avec les décisions que j'ai
prises là cette année mais ça que j'ai
plus cauchemar ceci dit ça fait un
moment que je n'ai pas fait c'est
peut-être lié au fait que jose montrer
qui je suis vraiment jose assumer mes
choix et mes actes et mes goûts et mes
envies de dire ce que j'ai envie de dire
et voilà la réponse allez ciao
donc si jamais vous faites les rêves un
peu chelou bas renseignez vous voilà ça
mange pas de pain et ça se trouve je dis
que de la merde et les pros las d'errer
avait tout ils vont me dire mais tu es
complètement complot et retourne dans ta
pyramide mais auront raison jose faire
ce que j'avais josette ce que suit et et
ça fait du bien [ __ ] c'est une belle
conclusion de vidéos que j'avais même
pas anticipé j'aime hydratée chers amis
d'internet c'est la fin de ce premier ya
quoi j'espère que ça vous a plu j'ai tu
peux le faire je me suis éclatée du
rialet heureusement il ya le montage
derrière et on va pouvoir bien rassure
couple et tous n'hésitez pas à soutenir
le format en me disant ce que vous en
avez sincèrement pensez dans les
commentaires en zinc petit constructive
je vais plein de bisous je vous dis à
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo et dans
un projet aqua page sur je suis épanoui
j'espère que vous aussi et je vous dirai
bientôt
bisous tout le monde bisous les p'tits
loulous eh ben c'est dommage de gâcher
toute la vidéo sur une phrase qui arrive
à la fin
[Musique]
et